Welcome back to human emotion.
Today we're going to be talking about
emotions as they relate to ourselves.
And we're going to be doing this by
first answering the question of what are
self conscious emotions.
So how many of you
recognize this painting?
So for those of you who don't,
this is a painting called narcissist,
a narcissist.
And the story of narcissists as depicted
in this painting tells us a young man
who falls in love with his own reflection,
gazing upon it.
As you can see in the water and modern
emotion theorists use this painting of
narcissists as a classic example of when
there's perhaps pathological levels of
self conscious emotions.
Too much of an emotion like pride.
And this is an emotion we'll be
discussing in class today. Um,
sometimes when people are thinking of
what our sort of modern kind of pop
culture, you know, contemporaries
of narcissist, I don't
know if the sunglasses,
um,
make you think of anyone in particular
for me and for many others out there when
they see these sunglasses, they think
of one of the pop culture. Um, you know,
songwriters of our day,
Kanye west who said in one of his songs
there's a thousand of use and only one
of me.
So let's think about this theme of self
conscious awareness and what kinds of
emotions my we experience when we're
really thinking about ourselves and how we
relate to the social world around us.
This is the realm of self conscious
emotions that we'll talk about today. Um,
a lot of this work has really
been pioneered by some of
the people you see here,
Jessica Tracy,
Richard Robbins,
and it's funny to see someone else
named June but June price tangy.
So they edited this book called the Self
conscious emotions theory and research.
Um, and this really contains
a lot of readings that
you'll see within the course.
I'm really drawing on the wide
scope of work in this field,
linking the self to how we feel.
So here's our roadmap for today.
We'll start out by really reviewing
what are the central features of self
conscious emotions.
So how are they different from some of
the emotions we've discussed thus far?
Like anger, sadness, happiness,
what is really different
about these emotions?
Then we'll go through some examples
of self conscious emotions followed by
takeaway questions and our
expert interview for the day.
So let's first start by defining some
features of really what makes an emotion
self conscious in the first place.
So when we think about the features
of self conscious emotions, um,
one of the first kind of core features
is that they involve a sense of self
awareness or the ability to have a
mental representation of I or me.
And so if you have a sense of yourself,
of the eye of the me,
then you have this ability
to be aware of yourself,
to have a sense of self knowledge,
which is absolutely in order to
experience self conscious emotions.
So since the first sort of central
feature of what makes up a self conscious
emotion experience and
there's others as well.
So the second feature that's really
different and unique about self conscious
emotions is that they are not innate.
These are not emotions like those
we've seen before, like you know,
sadness and crying or happiness
that emerge really early in life.
These are things that actually take
time to develop mentally emerge.
And here you can say see that they
don't emerge early in life as infants,
but they actually seem to come on much
later. So they emerge later in childhood,
often by the age of three.
So we're not seeing a sense of self
or awareness as well until that age.
So it's no surprise,
no surprise that we would see these
emotions as well take flight as soon as
they're just a mental representation of
the sense of self, a sense of I or me.
The third feature that's really important
about self conscious emotions is that
they also help facilitate social goals.
So they're really central not only to
sort of understanding one's sense of self,
but also to one understanding one sense
of self within a broader sort of social
group or social here.
Archi.
And so they play this really critical
role in helping us establish and maintain
these delicate social bonds and
relationships that we live as human beings
living in a social environment.
So in order to be social creatures,
one component that helps us
sort of navigate those, uh,
sort of waters is having the
experience of self conscious emotions.
And we'll go into that
more in just one bit. Um,
an interesting feature of
self conscious emotions,
which seems to really fly in the face
of everything we've talked about so far
with respect to emotions, which is
that they have a subjective experience.
They have an external, you
know, universally recognizable
behavioral display.
Um, you know, physiological parameters.
One of those three components we just
don't see when it comes to self conscious
emotions, at least not yet. We don't
know of any universal facial expressions.
Um, instead it seems that self
conscious emotions really, um,
the way that in which they're manifested
is really this combination of bodily
postures and head movements that
there's not just one universal facial
expression that can pick out these
emotions that involve a sense of self
awareness. And that really helped us
facilitate our social environment.
So you might wonder, well what do self
conscious emotions then look like?
And that will be something we'll talk
about today if we don't see them in the
face.
Where do we see them?
The fifth
feature about self conscious emotions is
that they're really cognitively complex,
much more so than the basic emotions
we talked about earlier. Again,
the ones that were evolutionary heart,
evolutionarily hardwired like anger,
disgust, sadness, fear and
happiness. So we're fear.
For example, a basic emotion really only
requires you appraising the environment,
it's being threatening or scary self
conscious emotions that we'll talk about
later.
Like shame and guilt and pride really
require these mark cognitively complex
representations. You have
to have, for example,
a stable representation
of yourself across time.
You have to have the cognitive ability
to self reflect upon your actions and
assess them against your own internal,
you know,
norms and past experiences
as well as sort of, you know,
evaluating against the broader social
norms that are external to the self.
So they are much more cognitively complex
than some of these basic emotions.
Not surprisingly, as we said,
they don't emerge until, you know,
later on in life as well
around the age of three.
When you start seeing glimmers of them.
So these are some of the five features
we've talked about that sort of help us
begin to understand what
our self conscious emotions.
And here again more much
more cognitively complex.
So we've talked about five features of
self conscious emotions that are really
sailing it,
kind of pick them out and differentiate
them from some of the more basic
emotions we've talked about thus far.
You may be wondering as I've
told you all these teachers,
they'll self conscious emotions.
Well well what are that?
It's self conscious emotions and what
are these funny emotions that are more
cognitively complex that don't
emerge until much later in life.
And that really seemed to involve a
sense of self awareness in order to
experience them.
So what I want to do now then is walk you
through some examples of what are some
of the prime candidates or examples that
have been discussed so far as really
kind of you know,
your poster child kind of icons for
the family of self conscious emotions.
So here I'm going to walk you through
four commonly discussed self conscious
emotions. And there is
follows. This includes pride,
embarrassment, shame, and guilt.
And what I'll do today is just walk you
through brief definitions of each and
then what we'll do for the remainder of
our module on self conscious emotions is
go into greater depth and, uh,
and each of these four emotions.
So let me give you a brief overview
today of these four really interesting,
uh,
examples of emotions that centrally
involved the self and an awareness of
oneself within a social group. These are
the family of self conscious emotions.
So let's start here with pride.
So what is pride in the first place?
So you know,
we think about what does pride look like
and if you look at these photos here,
you know, do you see examples of pride,
um, that are not only evident, you know,
in humans that are of the
bodybuilding, you know, variety,
but do we also see them in some
nonhuman primates as well? Sort of.
Is there a sense of elevating your sense
of self and sort of displaying your
social status that makes up
what the nature of pride is?
Um, and here if we talk about what
are the characteristics of pride,
I break it up into three categories
here with respect to the solicitor.
So what triggers pride,
what is the associated behavior of pride
and what are some of the consequences
of experiencing pride?
So pride is typically elicited if we
start here at the far left by some sort of
personal achievement or success.
So the self has had some
sort of accomplishment that
is really directed towards
yourself. Something good has happened
to you, you've achieved some goal,
you've obtained some reward,
you've gotten some sort of self praise
or recognition and the behaviors we saw
earlier in the bodybuilder and even
the chimpanzee seems to signal a way in
which you're sort of puffing out
your, your posture, your advertising,
advertising to others that you have an
elevated sense of status. It's like,
look at me,
I'm important right now.
And so you're signaling
to others as it says here,
I'm a successful person who deserves some
sort of recognition and perhaps higher
status within my social group. So
again, it's this very like, you know,
expanding your posture and
saying, look at me, I'm important.
And the consequence of this sort of
experience and display of pride is thought
to be,
um,
sort of focus towards gaining
respect within your social hierarchy.
You achieve something,
you display it,
and that should boost you up within
the social ladder that you live in.
So these are some of the characteristics
of what pride is thought to sort of be
about and sort of the ultimate social
goals that it's supposed to fulfill.
So that's a little bit about pride.
Now let's briefly walk through the
nature of embarrassment here. Again,
we're just going to go through some
of the basic features of what makes up
embarrassment. And I remember in our
very first class we sort of opened up,
you know, the topic of emotion by
having you think about, you know,
an example of a time in your life in
which you made a major social phobia and
had this almost painful
experience of embarrassment.
Now what good would embarrassment serve?
Why would we want to be
experiencing it in the first place?
And why are we hardwired
or built to be embarrassed.
So here I'll walk you through the
characteristics of embarrassment,
just like I did with pride.
So when we think of the solicitor,
so what is it that gets pride or
sorry gets embarrassment going.
We see that embarrassing.
It gets triggered when an individual
violates some sort of social convention or
norm. Again, they transgress. Um,
what is known to be a social rule.
They make a social fo pos.
So this could be saying something that
feels really stupid in front of a new
colleague or boss. It could be, you know,
just tripping in front of other people.
I always joke that I spill things a lot
like this, you know, Star Trek Coffee Mug.
So you can, you know, spill
coffee on someone. You're
doing something that's not,
you know, within the normal
bounds of social behavior.
And so you feel embarrassed and the kind
of behavior that you display is really
intended to let others know that
you know that you made a mistake,
you know you the social pho par,
but that the behavior suggest that you
have the intention or desire to remedy
that social transgression and ultimately
repair your social relationships with
others. So it's a way of saying, look,
I know what I did was
socially unacceptable.
I'm really sorry I want to repair
this with you. I want to remedy it.
And not surprisingly,
what happens when people show
embarrassment displays is that they elicit
forgiveness and others they become
more likable. As you can see here,
it elicits laughter and others and
actually makes people trust you more.
So there's been some studies that have
shown that people who are more prone to
experiencing and displaying embarrassment
or often rated as more likable and
trustworthy by others because in a
sense what you're doing is saying,
I know that I made a mistake and
I want to make things better.
And that makes people feel like they
can trust you and they like you,
that when you do violate social norms,
you're going to do something
about it to correct it.
So those are some of the kind of
key features or characteristics of
embarrassment.
Now we'll turn to shame.
So what is shame? It's a word that we
use a lot in our daily lives will stand.
I'm ashamed of what I did
or you're ashamed of someone
else. And it seems to be,
as you see this quote here that shames
and essential or core part of humankind's.
So it says here,
men cannot live without shame.
A sense of shame is the
beginning of integrity.
So is there something about shame that
pushes us towards more sort of morally
righteous or prosocial outcomes?
Well,
when we think about shame from a sort
of aspect of science perspective, again,
breaking it up by all this sitter behavior
and consequence, we see the following.
So things that tend to trigger shame
are committing acts or being in certain
situations that trigger you to sort
of negatively evaluate yourself.
Right? Sort of thinking that something
might be wrong with you as a whole,
as a person. So it's kind of
a global evaluation of the
self in a negative light.
Um, some of the behaviors that
are associated with shame, again,
you don't see a characteristic
shame display in the face. Again,
what you see as a sense of a behavior
that is intended to sort of make the
person physically appear smaller.
So people hunched over in their posture
and they'll even sort of pull away from
the group and sort of go and retreat.
So you can imagine someone
sort of hunched up, you know,
in a little ball in the corner.
So it's a sense of making
yourself invisible in the
eyes of others and actually
trying to find ways to make
yourself look physically smaller.
So then in many ways it's the complete
opposite of pride where you're expanding
your sense of self and you're looking
to gain recognition from others.
Shame is you're diminishing your sense
of self physically trying to look smaller
and you're retreating from the group.
And the consequence here is interesting.
So it seems that you're less likely to
take any corrective action against what
you think is negative about yourself,
but instead you sort of
withdraw and retreat. Um,
so Shane doesn't really seem to have the
kinds of pro social consequences that
we sipped seen so far with both pride
and embarrassment. So with that,
let's turn to our fourth self
conscious emotion, which is guilt. Um,
and I'm sure we can all think of in our
daily lives times in which you've done
something that we felt guilty about.
Now,
how is this different from feeling
shame about something that we did?
So let's walk through this
really quickly. So guilt, um,
we've all experienced
this in our daily lives.
We cannot think of something that
made us feel guilty, but really what,
what were the kind of key ingredients
that made up that feeling of guilt?
So here again, breaking it up by a
solicitor behavior and consequence.
What we see is that the kind of core
characteristics of gilts are as follows.
So what kind of triggers guilt?
What kind of gets it going?
Is this a negative evaluation
of one's action? So again, here,
you're not negatively
evaluating the self as a whole.
What you're doing is evaluating
some specific action you did.
So for example, if you stole
something, you might have the thought,
I can't believe I store.
Um,
this then sets off a series of
behaviors where you actually become very
motivated to address
or remedy the problems.
So maybe looking for ways to return the
item that you store or to find ways to
apologize for having stolen
the item as a consequence. Um,
and you'll see this is really different
from what we just talked about in the
context of shame,
is that guilt actually does motivate
these kind of prosocial, uh,
you know, good outcomes.
So as you can see here,
it's described as motivating good
consequences such as trying to address the
problem.
So guilt is interesting because it's about
an action or behavior and really gets
the person mobilized to try to do
something about it, to try to correct it,
such as this woman who,
you know,
maybe he feels guilty because she ate
something from the fridge that she wasn't
supposed to do,
or maybe with someone else's food.
She's going to be more motivated to maybe
do something about that in the future.
And so again,
these are our four main self conscious
emotions that we'll be talking about in
the subsequent two modules
where we go more in depth,
kind of delve into more deeply the nature
of pride and embarrassment followed by
the really complex nature of shame and
guilt and what ways they're similar and
what ways they're actually quite distinct.
And so with that was our introduction
to the world of self conscious emotions.
I want to conclude with
our takeaway questions.
So the takeaway questions for
today, um, are as follows,
the first and what you should make sure
you understand here is what are the five
distinct features of self conscious
emotions that really make them unique and
differentiate them from some of the
more basic emotions that we discussed
earlier.
A second.
What are the examples we just talked about
a moment ago of the most for commonly
discussed, uh, self conscious
emotions in the literature.
And then finally of these four
motions that we discussed,
can you name the solicitor behavior and
associated consequence for each of these
self conscious emotions.
And now we'll turn to
our expert interview. Um,
and here we'll be asking them to speak
with us about their perspective on self
conscious emotions. So here's our experts
in emotion interview series for today.
Um, today for the experts
in emotion interview.
We'll have the honor speaking
with Doctor Jessica Tracy. Um,
Dr Tracy is an associate professor of
psychology at the University of British
Columbia in Vancouver,
Canada where she's also a Michael Smith
Foundation for health research scholar
and the Canadian Institute for
Health Research new investigator.
She received her phd from the
University of California Davis in 2005.
Doctor Tracy's research focuses on
emotions and emotion expressions and in
particular on the self conscious
emotions of pride, shame, and guilt.
She was the lead editor of the self
conscious emotions edited handbook we saw
earlier in class and is currently an
associate editor at the journal emotion.
Dr Tracy has published
over 60 journal articles,
book chapters and
theoretical reviews in 2005.
She won the James Mckean Katell
dissertation award from the New York,
New York Academy of Sciences.
And in 2010 the international society for
self and identity, early career award.
And then later in 2011 at University
of British Columbia Kill him research
prize. Dr Tracy's research has been
covered by numerous media outlets,
including ABC's Good
Morning America and prs,
all things considered the New York Times,
the Los Angeles Times, the Boston Globe,
the economist, the New Scientist, and
scientific American among many others.
So I now turn to our experts and emotion
interview with Doctor Jessica Tracy.